en 1927
cinq femmes dont emily murphy qui
voulait devenir sénatrice vont écrire au
gouvernement fédéral du canada pour leur
demander s'il est possible pour une
femme d'avoir un poste de sénateur
le gouvernement fédéral va à son tour se
tourner vers la cour suprême et va
demander à la cour suprême si une
personne de sexe féminin a les
compétences requises au sens de
l'article 24 de la rrq d'amérique du
nord britannique pour accéder au sénat
la cour suprême va répondre que en 1877
les femmes n'ayant pas le droit de faire
de la politique
elles ne pouvaient pas être des
personnes au sens entendu par la
constitution et que donc les femmes ne
sont pas des personnes pouvant accéder à
la fonction de sénateur
nos cinq familles vont être plutôt vexés
ils vont alors se tourner vers ceux qui
à l'époque le plus haut tribunal du pays
le comité judiciaire du conseil privé
les l'art du conseil privé va invalider
la décision de la cour suprême du canada
est déterminé qu on ne peut pas au xxème
siècle interpréter la constitution
canadienne comme on l'aurait fait en
ils vont aussi statué que à cette époque
moderne empêcher les femmes d'accéder à
la politique c'est faire preuve d'un
attitude qui appartient à un temps
révolu et barbare
morale de cette histoire madame murphy
ne deviendra pas sénatrice c'est plutôt
karen elson qui va accéder au sénat à